Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the podcast that knows its plague from its pestilence. Do you know, I'm reading that from script and basically plague is pestilence, isn't it? But whatever. Okay, anyway, moving on. I'm Tom Holland. I'm a historian of the ancient world. And I am Dominic Sandbrook, historian of the moderns. Tom, that introduction was seamless. Beginning as I hope we carry on. Today, what we're going to ask is, what with pestilence, or plague, depending what you want to call it, statue smashing, the government on the verge of
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的加更剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先收看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com，加入这个能分清“瘟疫”（plague）和“疫病”（pestilence）的播客。你知道吗，我是照着稿子念的，其实瘟疫和疫病是一回事，对吧？但无所谓了。好吧，总之，继续往下说。我是汤姆·霍兰德，一位研究古代世界的历史学家。我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，研究现代史的历史学家。汤姆，那段开场白真是天衣无缝。希望我们能保持这个势头。今天，我们要探讨的是，伴随着疫病——或者瘟疫，随你怎么叫——砸毁雕像，政府正处于
treating Christmas as a time of solemn humiliation. Are we living through a 17th century moment? So we'll tease that out very shortly. But before that, we've had some interesting correspondence following our first two episodes. We have indeed, Tom. So our first episode, as you may remember, was about greatness. And we asked why, Tom, apart, we don't have any great people anymore. And we had now the British ambassador to Lugash. That is a splendid Return of the Pink Panther reference there. The British
将圣诞节视为庄严忏悔时刻的边缘。我们是否正经历着一个17世纪的时刻？我们稍后会详细剖析。但在那之前，继前两期节目之后，我们收到了一些有趣的来信。确实如此，汤姆。正如大家所记得的，我们的第一期节目是关于“伟大”。我们问，汤姆，为什么除了我们之外，现在没有伟人了？我们现在有了卢加什（Lugash）的英国大使。那真是对《粉红豹归来》的精彩引用。英国
ambassador to Lugash got in touch to say, he says, I think you may have underplayed Xi. The arc of development and change he will see to fruition is exactly is exactly what gets the great tag i'm not saying it's right but china has entered modernity and regained self-regard the evils will be glossed over as will the credit due to the west actually there's a lot of truth in that i think xi jinping will go down in chinese sort of memory is a great leader um but will he be called will he be called the great thing i mean that's that's will he be well in chinese maybe he will yeah well it's i mean it's it's you know we we said yet in in the episode that it's a greek thing um and so very suitably we have something from hypatia cassandra 2020 who suggests i think you have to be a conqueror or at least a unifier
卢加什大使联系我们说，他认为我们可能低估了习。他将实现的变革与发展轨迹，正是被贴上“伟大”标签的原因。我不是说这是对的，但中国已经进入了现代性并重拾了自尊，其中的罪恶会被掩盖，就像归功于西方的功绩一样。其实这很有道理。我认为习近平在中国的记忆中会作为一位伟大的领导人被铭记，但会被称为“伟大”吗？我是说，在中文里也许会吧。是的，正如我们在节目中所说，这是一个希腊式的概念。所以非常应景的是，我们收到了来自“希帕提娅·卡珊德拉2020”（Hypatia Cassandra 2020）的建议，她认为你必须是一位征服者，或者至少是一位统一者。
erdogan would certainly like the title since he buried Ataturkism and brought back a more Ottoman mindset, but I don't think posterity would give it to him. Well, I guess it depends if he conquers Vienna. We'll have to wait and see. Yeah. Well, he has the self-image though, doesn't he? As great people do. He believes himself to be great and that's often half the battle. Anyway, other suggestions. We had The Queen and Jimmy Anderson. I assume they were both from you, Tom, right? I completely agree about Jimmy Anderson, yeah.
埃尔多安肯定会喜欢这个头衔，因为他埋葬了凯末尔主义，带回了更具奥斯曼色彩的思维方式，但我认为后世不会给他这个称号。好吧，我想这取决于他是否征服了维也纳。我们拭目以待。是的，但他有那种自我形象，不是吗？正如伟人所拥有的那样。他相信自己是伟大的，这往往就成功了一半。总之，还有其他建议。我们有女王和吉米·安德森。我猜这些都是你提的，汤姆，对吧？我完全同意关于吉米·安德森的看法，是的。
And Graham Burton wins this one with the very straightforward suggestion, Boris the Great Big Idiot. Martin Bright, the distinguished journalist, who was played by Matt Smith in the film Official Secrets, said that an admiral had a long lunch with him around 1999 and said, give me a militia and my own newspaper and I could provoke a civil war between England and Scotland tomorrow. I guess that would actually be quite a lot easier now than it was in 1999. Which of us hasn't dreamed of having his own militia in his own newspaper? I mean if I won the lottery they're the two things I would immediately you know I'd buy the Chipping Norton advertiser and set up my own branch of some guy who knows yeah you kind of want your
格雷厄姆·伯顿以一个非常直白的建议赢得了这一轮：伟大的大白痴鲍里斯。马丁·布莱特，那位在电影《官方机密》中由马特·史密斯饰演的杰出记者，说一位海军上将曾在1999年左右与他共进午餐，并说：“给我一支民兵和一份我自己的报纸，我明天就能挑起英格兰和苏格兰之间的内战。”我想现在这比1999年要容易得多。我们之中谁没梦想过拥有自己的民兵和报纸呢？我是说，如果我中了彩票，这两件事我肯定会立刻去做，你知道的，我会买下《奇平诺顿广告报》，然后建立我自己的分支机构，有人懂的，是的，你确实想要你自己的
own militia don't you Tom? Yeah of course. Brixton Defence Force. Yes, I'd start with Brickston, then a next South London. And from there, I'd gradually move out and it would be the world. Well, we have one other point from John Zmirak before we move on. He says, an excellent podcast. What a fine judge he is. I would suggest that Tom consider whether, yeah, Tom, consider whether the moral claims to greatness filed by the like of Nelson Mandela are just a different means of asserting power. Yes, I mean, sainthood traditionally was a source of power, but not, I think, power in
民兵，不是吗，汤姆？是的，当然。布里克斯顿国防军。是的，我会从布里克斯顿开始，然后是南伦敦。从那里开始，我会逐渐扩张，最终是全世界。好吧，在继续之前，我们还有约翰·兹米拉克的一点意见。他说，这是一个很棒的播客。他真是个有眼光的人。我建议汤姆考虑一下，是的，汤姆，考虑一下纳尔逊·曼德拉这类人所提出的伟大道德主张，是否只是主张权力的一种不同手段。是的，我是说，圣徒身份传统上是一种权力来源，但我认为，那不是亚历山大大帝意义上的权力。所以，感谢所有对“伟大”这一概念的评论。在第二期节目中，我们探讨了现代工业国家发生内战所需的条件。名字很棒的“胡须将军”联系我们谈到了美国，并说，很难看出美国目前的红州和蓝州如何能正式分裂。但以目前所谓的领导力来看，这是可能的。中部州对阵边缘州，一个有趣的场景。我确实看到一个想法，红州可能想脱离并组建自己的国家，而蓝州或许可以加入加拿大。是的，这不现实，但并非不可能，不是吗？我是说，这就是……这对我来说完全不现实。但如果你要想象一个美国在
the kind of Alexander the Great sense. So anyway, thanks to all those comments on the idea of greatness. In episode two, we wondered about the conditions required for a civil war to take place in a modern industrial country. The splendidly named General Whiskers got in touch with regard to the US and said, tricky to see how the current red and blue states of the USA could divide as formally. But with current so-called leadership, it is possible. Central states versus peripheral states, an interesting scenario. I did see one idea that the red states might want to break off and form their own country and the blue states could perhaps join Canada. Yeah, it's unrealistic, but not impossible, isn't it? I mean, that's how... It seems completely unrealistic to me. But if you were going to imagine a nightmare scenario for the US
在接下来的，比如说接下来的100年里的噩梦场景，也许是在你我死后，但当我们孩子死的时候……这是你想表达的吗？是的，我是在预测一些我死后会发生的事情。我很有信心，我不会为此负责。想象分裂并非完全不可思议，对吧？或者想象某种州政府不再听从联邦政府指挥的情况。
in the next, let's say in the next hundred years, so maybe when you and I are dead, but when our children are dead... Is that you getting at it? Yeah, I'm predicting something that's going to happen when I'm dead. I'm pretty confident that I won't be held to account for it. It's not utterly implausible to imagine secession, right? Or to imagine some kind of situation where you have the state governments no longer taking direction from the federal government.
我是说，美国体制中一直存在这种僵局。你现在看到的是这种根深蒂固的分裂，不是吗？在沿海地区和中部地区之间，在心脏地带和自由派大都市边缘之间。你看到了。我是说，这次选举最非同寻常的地方在于，尽管经历了过去四年，唐纳德·特朗普的支持率依然如此坚韧。这些人，你知道，现在会说选举是从他手中窃取的，诸如此类。所以，你知道，这些分歧不会消失。而且这并非完全……
I mean, you have these standoffs in the American system all the time. What you've got right now is this entrenched division, don't you, between the coasts and the centre, between the heartland and the kind of liberal metropolitan fringes. And you see that. I mean, that's the extraordinary thing about this election right now, is that despite the last four years, Donald Trump's support has been so resilient. And these are people who, you know, now are going to say that the election was stolen from him and all the rest of it. So, you know, those divisions are not going to go away. And it's not entirely,
我是说，好吧，这非常、非常不现实，但奇怪的事情总会发生。你真的认为加拿大……会吞并……是的，恢复英属北美，我是说，这基本上是我活着的意义，而且……是的，所以英格兰在北美的参与确实是在17世纪开始的，不是吗，多米尼克？这使我们能够流畅地转换话题。那确实是天衣无缝的。那真是天衣无缝。
I mean, okay, it's very, very very unrealistic but strange things happen do you really think that canada would uh would annex yeah the restoration of british north america i mean that's basically what i live for and um yes and so so british english engagement in north america uh really yeah kind of kicked in in the 17th century, doesn't it, Dominic? Which enables us to pivot fluidly. That is actually seamless. That is seamless.
是的。是的。所以是时候把注意力转向本周的主题了：疫病与瘟疫、砸毁雕像、圣诞节的庄严、内战、阴谋，
Yes. Yes. So it's time to turn our attention to this week's subject, pestilence and plague, statue bashing, solemnity at Christmas, civil war, plots,
以及所有其他相关内容。汤姆·霍兰德，我们真的在回到17世纪吗？好吧，首先，给我们一些背景。很多人不知道，你知道，不会知道我们在说什么。所以给我们讲讲发生了什么。好的，很棒的建议。伊丽莎白一世去世。继位的是苏格兰的詹姆斯六世，斯图亚特王朝的国王，他成为了英格兰的詹姆斯一世。继位的是他的儿子查理一世，他留着尖胡子和极其引人注目的八字胡。他们最终在英格兰、苏格兰以及爱尔兰——斯图亚特王朝统治的地方——
all the rest of it. Tom Holland, are we actually returning to the 17th century? Well, first of all, give us some sense. A lot of people don't know, you know, won't know what we're talking about. So give us some sense of what happened. Okay, great tips. Elizabeth I dies. She gets succeeded by James VI of Scotland, Stuart King, who becomes James I of England. He is succeeded by his son, Charles I, who has a pointy beard and a sensational moustache. They end up in England, Scotland, Ireland as well, which the Stuart monarchy rules,
陷入了内战。查理一世被砍了头。奥利弗·克伦威尔建立了护国公政体。克伦威尔去世。查理一世的儿子查理二世复辟。1665年伦敦爆发瘟疫。第二年，伦敦被烧毁。查理二世是一位快乐的君主，与各种人有染，包括内尔·格温。他去世后，由他的兄弟詹姆斯继位，他是一位天主教徒，这在绝大多数新教徒占主导地位的英格兰并不受欢迎。詹姆斯二世最终被赶走，由威廉继位，他是一个荷兰人，这基本上建立了一种模式，随后在安妮女王统治下延续到18世纪。干得好，汤姆。那是一场精彩的表演。人们听完这个都能去考A-level了。
implodes into a civil war. Charles I has his head chopped off. A protectorate is established under Oliver Cromwell. Cromwell dies. Charles I's son, Charles II, is restored. Plague hits London in 1665. The following year, London burns down. Charles II is a merry monarch, has affairs with all kinds of people, including Nell Gwynne. He dies, is replaced by his brother, James who is a Catholic this is not popular with massive majority Protestant England who James II ends up getting chased out is replaced by William who is a Dutchman and this essentially establishes a kind of model that then goes through under the reign of Queen Anne into the 18th century. Good stuff, Tom. That was a bravura performance. People can do their A-levels after that.
所以让我们深入探讨其中一件事，也许是瘟疫，因为那是显而易见的。显然，我们是在封锁的第一天做这个节目。他们在伦敦也有封锁，不是吗？实际上是在1665年瘟疫爆发时。是的，宫廷撤退到了牛津，最有趣的细节是，住在牛津的古物研究者安东尼·伍德报告说，他们基本上在牛津的各个学院里露营等等。当宫廷离开，瘟疫结束后，人们搬回去发现，朝臣们在他们的住处到处拉屎。是的。非常恶心。这在牛津的行为，肯定是的。
So let's just go in on one of those things, maybe the plague, because that's the most obvious. Obviously, we're doing this on the first day of the lockdown. They had a lockdown too in London, didn't they, effectively, in 1665 when the plague hit? Yes, and the court retreats to Oxford, where the most entertaining detail, the antiquary Anthony Wood, who lived in Oxford, reports that they kind of camped out in the various Oxford colleges and so on. And when the court then left, when the plague had ended, people moved back in and discovered that the courtiers had left turds all over their accommodation. Yeah. Very nasty. They stand at Oxford Behaviour, surely.
安东尼·伍德说，非常恶心和野蛮。是的，有很多有趣的相似之处，不是吗？所以我正在读塞缪尔·佩皮斯的日记。佩皮斯，正如许多人所知，就是那个在1660年代查理二世复辟和伦敦生活期间写下这本精彩日记的人。佩皮斯说了一些话，比如，你知道，他不想买假发。他不想买新假发，因为他担心它基本上会被瘟疫所浸透。是的，被瘟疫病毒感染。他说，他想知道有多少人会去买假发，因为他们会非常
Very nasty and beastly, Anthony Wood says. Yeah, and there's so many funny parallels, aren't there? So I was reading Samuel Pepys's diary. Pepys, as many people will know, is this guy who writes this fantastic diary during the 1660s of Charles II's restoration and life in London and so on. And Peep sort of says things like, you know, he doesn't want to get a wig. He doesn't want to get a new wig because he fears it will basically be sort of suffused with plague. Yeah, infected with plague virus. And he says, he wonders how many people are going to be getting wigs because they'll be so
担心自己被感染。这就像，你知道，人们给邮件消毒或者人们做的任何事情。他们对感染新冠感到非常恐慌。是的，我想，我是说，显然，瘟疫和疫病在历史上席卷过英国。你知道，我们在这次大流行的经历中听到了所有关于它们的事情。但我认为，关于17世纪瘟疫和灾难经历的一个有趣之处在于，它与气候变化的感觉有关。所以这在今天又是一个有趣的相似之处。对，因为这是小冰河时期，不是吗？所以气温下降了，我想，大约一度，在整个欧洲。是的，伟大的历史学家杰弗里·帕克有一本精彩的书，
worried that they're infected. And that's just like, you know, people disinfecting their post or whatever it is people do. And they're very alarmed about getting COVID. Yeah, I think, I mean, obviously, plague and pestilence has swept Britain across history. You know, we've heard all about them over the experience of this current pandemic. But I think that one of the things that is interesting about the 17th century experience of plague and catastrophes generally is that it's linked to a sense of climate change. So that is a kind of interesting parallel again today. Right, because this is the period of the Little Ice Age, isn't it? So temperatures dropped, I think, by about a degree, generally across Europe. Yeah, and there's a fantastic book by the great historian Geoffrey Parker,
《全球危机》，他在书中将英国的经历、英国陷入内战的崩溃、大流行的经历置于气候变化的背景下，他将其置于一个完全全球的视角，并追溯了这样一种感觉：在全世界范围内，这是一个毁灭性的革命、战争和崩溃时期。未来的历史学家是否会回顾21世纪初，说我们正在经历的动荡是由气候变化驱动的，我不知道。但这是一种，它确实是一个有趣的相似之处。但这是一个可怕的相似之处，对吧，汤姆？因为我读过那本书。
Global Crisis, where he puts the experience of Britain, the implosion of Britain into civil war, the experience of pandemic against this backdrop of climate change, and he puts it in an entirely global perspective and kind of traces the sense that across the entire world, this is a devastating period of revolution, of war, of collapse. And whether future historians will look back at the early 21st century and say that the convulsions that we're living through were driven by climate change, I don't know. But it's kind of, it is an interesting parallel. But it's a terrifying parallel, right, Tom? Because I've read that book.
它大约有6000页长。我是说，简直是一本巨著。在那本书中，他指出在17世纪的欧洲大部分地区，人口实际上减少了大约三分之一。在德国，减少了一半。所以在德国，你有三十年战争在进行。人们在德国各地的村庄里被谋杀、强奸、屠杀、折磨，到处都是。
It's about 6,000 pages long. I mean, just a colossal book. And in that book, he points out that in much of Europe, the population in the 17th century actually dropped by about a third. In Germany, it fell by half. So in Germany, you've got the 30 years war going on. People are being kind of murdered, raped, butchered, tortured, left, right and centre in villages all across Germany.
如果你认为，你知道，每两个人中就有一个人基本上死了，你就能感受到那个世纪在人们心理上留下的巨大文化创伤。好吧，这就是为什么我认为，观察我们这个时代与17世纪的相似之处，以及对比，会很有趣，因为我想这会让人们振作起来，因为尽管现在看起来很糟糕，但它们并没有当时那么糟糕。当然，你知道，我们对新冠的经历与1665年伦敦的瘟疫经历相比简直微不足道。我想伦敦大约有十万人死于1665年。那大约是人口的四分之一。而且，你知道，有所有这些关于尸体被扔进瘟疫坑等等的故事。
And if you think, you know, one in every two people basically dies you get a sense of the sort of the massive cultural scar that that century left on people's sort of psyche well that's why i thought that it would be interesting to uh to look not only at the parallels of our present age with the 17th century but also the contrast because i thought that that would cheer people up because terrible though things may seem at the moment they're not as bad as they were and of course you know our experience of of of covid is as nothing compared to london's experience of of plague in 1665 about a hundred thousand people i think died in london in 16. That's about a quarter of the population. And, you know, there's all these stories about bodies being dumped in plague pits and all the rest of it.
我们没有处于那种境地，对吧？我们没有处于那种境地。当然，尽管我们现在可能觉得国家充满了分歧，但它们与17世纪困扰英国的分歧相比根本不算什么。当然，特别是在1665年伦敦瘟疫之前的几十年里。所以，在1640年代和50年代，当英格兰、苏格兰和威尔士真正被暴力内战蹂躏时。我是说，以一种致命的规模，我想，多米尼克。是的，我认为1640年代内战中每人死亡的人数比两次世界大战中死亡的人数还要多。
We're not in that situation, are we? We are not in that situation. And of course, although we may feel now that the country is riven with divisions, they are nothing like the divisions that afflicted Britain over the course of the 17th century. And of course, particularly in the decades that had preceded the plague of London in 1665. So over the course of the 1640s and 50s, when England and Scotland too and Wales was really ravaged by violent civil war. I mean, on a kind of lethal scale, I think, Dominic. Yeah, I think more people died in the Civil Wars of the 1640s per head than died in either of the World Wars.
我是说，这说明了你需要知道的一切。但你知道吗，汤姆，谈到分歧，我认为一个迷人的相似之处是，这些分歧在多大程度上是由技术和新媒体驱动的。所以在17世纪，你有印刷机，你有小册子，你真正有了报纸的诞生。所以人们在阅读这些极其煽动性的报纸，告诉他们新教徒在欧洲遭受的暴行，或者天主教徒据称在爱尔兰实施的暴行。这在某种程度上把他们煽动到了狂热的状态。
I mean, that tells you all you need to know. But you know what, Tom, talking about the divisions, something that I think is a fascinating parallel is the extent to which the divisions are driven by technology and new media. So in the 17th century, you have the printing press, you have pamphlets, you have the birth of newspapers, really. So people are reading these incredibly inflammatory newspapers telling them about atrocities that Protestants are suffering in Europe or that Catholics are supposedly carrying out in Ireland. And this is sort of whipping them up into a frenzy.
真的，这与人们被推特、脸书等平台上的虚假信息、错误信息煽动到狂热的程度有什么不同吗？这是一个正在努力管理信息爆炸的社会，就像我们一样。而且，我想，你还有所谓的传统媒体被替代新闻来源所取代。你确实有这种情况。17世纪的传统媒体是什么？好吧，我想传统媒体是……由王室许可的小册子……对吧，当然，随着王室权威——特别是在伦敦——的崩溃，然后在1650年代完全消失，你确实有这种
And really, is that so different from the extent to which people are whipped up into a frenzy by false information, misinformation on Twitter and Facebook and all the rest of it. It's a society struggling to manage an explosion of information, as we are. And also you have, I guess, what we would call the mainstream media being replaced by alternative news sources. And you very much have that. What's the mainstream media in the 17th century? Well, I suppose the mainstream media is is is um pamphlets that are licensed um right by the crown and of course as as the crown's authority particularly in london collapses and then goes completely in the 1650s you do have this
令人难以置信的爆炸……而著名地庆祝这一点的人是约翰·弥尔顿。诗人。诗人，《失乐园》的作者。英联邦时期克伦威尔的秘书。查理一世被处决最著名的国际辩护者。所以从某种意义上说，他是克伦威尔政权的宣传主管。但他完全庆祝这个想法，你知道，让百花齐放。言论自由，
incredible explosion um and the the man who famously celebrates this is John Milton. The poet. The poet, author of Paradise Lost. Secretary to Cromwell during the Commonwealth. The most prominent international defender of the execution of Charles I. So in a sense, the kind of, you know, the chief of propaganda for Cromwell's regime. But he completely celebrates this idea, you know, the chief of propaganda for Cromwell's regime. But he completely celebrates this idea, you know, let a million flowers bloom. Freedom of speech,
完全如此。但当然，人们，就像我们现在一样，开始说，哦，我真的不确定我们是否想要这种东西出来。我想我们需要尝试控制它，尝试监管它。所以他们有这种整个言论自由的斗争，就像我们一样，对吧？我是说，这对他们来说是一个大问题。我想这是一个旧秩序试图压制新技术发展，压制日益增长的文盲人口。这是一个公平的说法吗？是的，但这也关乎什么是可能被相信和公开表达的爆炸，因为内战的部分原因是宗教。如果你生活在一个虔诚的基督教国家，而英格兰在17世纪确实如此，那么人们对宗教的看法就非常重要。
completely. But of course, people, rather as we do now, people start to say, oh, I'm not actually sure whether we want this kind of stuff coming out. I think we need to try and rein it in, try and regulate it. So they have this whole freedom of speech battle as we do, right? I mean, this is a big issue for them. I suppose it's an old order trying to put a lid on new technological development, on a growing illiterate population. Is that a fair? Yeah, but it's also about the explosion of what it is possible to believe and to express publicly, because part of what the Civil War is about is religious. And if you live in a devoutly Christian country, which England certainly was in the 17th century, then what people are saying about religion matters
但很多人会被这一点搞糊涂，不是吗？因为我记得当我做的时候，你知道，我热爱17世纪。我A-level学过它。但我记得大约10年前，我和一家大型出版社的编辑谈过。我告诉他17世纪有多精彩。他说，从来没有人买关于17世纪的书，因为它完全令人困惑。它全是关于祭坛的位置。而且，你知道，你被允许有圣徒的画像吗？
hugely. But a lot of people will be baffled by that, won't they? Because I remember when I did, you know, I loved the 17th century. I did it for A-level. But I can remember talking to an editor at a very big publishing house about 10 years ago. And I was telling him how brilliant the 17th century was. And he said, nobody ever buys books in the 17th century because it's all completely baffling. It's all about the placement of the altar. And, you know, are you allowed to have pictures of saints?
你被允许，牧师，人们为了牧师应该穿什么法衣或者他们使用什么祈祷书而互相残杀。对很多人来说，这完全令人困惑。是的，我同意。我认为这就是为什么我说，你知道，人们对历史上其他看起来不那么令人困惑的时期有更大的兴趣。但我真的认为17世纪很重要。宗教很重要，因为它是人们对国家走向的感知的基础。如果你对上帝想要什么有强烈的感知，那么对17世纪中叶的大多数人来说，让全国每个人都认同这一点很重要，因为如果他们不这样做，上帝的愤怒就会降临到这个国家。所以，国家教会应该是什么，
And are you allowed, is a priest, people are killing each other about what vestments a priest should wear or whatever, or what prayer book they use. To a lot of people that's completely baffling. Yes, I agree. And I think that that's why I say, you know, there's much greater interest in other periods of history that seem to be less baffling. But I really think the 17th century does matter. Religion matters because it's fundamental to people's sense of where the country is going. And if you have a passionate sense of what God wants, then it's important for most people in the middle of the 17th century that everybody in the country subscribes to that, because if they don't, the wrath of God will descend on the country. And so therefore, the question of what the national church should be,
人们认同什么信仰，就变得极其重要。而在1650年代，在国王被处决、护国公政体建立之后，这种理解开始碎片化，你得到了越来越多的宗教团体，他们开始觉得，全国是否都相信你的想法其实并不重要。重要的是一种良心自由，一种表达你宗教观点的自由。从某种意义上说，你知道，那是在展望未来。那最终是国家将要走向的地方。很好。好吧，休息一下的完美时机。当我们回来时，我们将回答你们关于17世纪一切事物的一些问题。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起
what beliefs people subscribe to, is hugely significant. And part of what happens over the course of the 1650s, after the execution of the king, the establishment of the protectorate, is that that understanding starts to fragment and you get increasing numbers of religious groups who come to feel that it doesn't actually matter whether the whole country believes what you think. What matters is a kind of freedom of conscience, a freedom to express your religious views. And in a sense, you know, that is looking forward to the future. That is where ultimately the country will end up. Nice. All right. Perfect place to take a short break. And when we return, we're going to be answering some of your questions on the subject of everything so 17th century i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together
主持《历史的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更剧集和抢先获得现场票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。如果你喜欢这个播客，请务必订阅、评分和评论，并通过推特与我们联系，发表你的评论、问题、谩骂和纠正。这一条来自乔纳森·希利，他的推特账号是 SocialHistoryFox。
we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the resterestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Do please subscribe, rate and review the pod if you've enjoyed it and get in touch with us on Twitter with your comments, questions, abuse and corrections. This one is from Jonathan Healy, who tweets as SocialHistoryFox.
我相信他过去在推特上骂过人，但不管怎样，我们就不计较了。一位非常、非常、非常杰出的17世纪历史学家，而且在推特上非常活跃，多米尼克，所以说话要小心。我刚才还以为你在说我，直到你提到17世纪。注意他说我们也有一个与主教制（即主教们）开战的统治者。他与苏格兰的关系有问题，现在还禁止了盖伊·福克斯之夜。他到底在说谁，汤姆·霍兰德？所以他就在那里，
I believe he's slagging off on Twitter in the past, but anyway, we'll let that go. A very, very, very distinguished historian of the 17th century and very active on Twitter, Dominic, so be careful what you say. I thought you were talking about me for a second until you mentioned the 17th century. Note that he says that we also have a ruler who has picked a fight with the episcopacy, i.e. bishops. He has a problematic relationship with Scotland and has now banned Guy Fawkes Knight. Who on earth could he be talking about, Tom Holland? So there he is,
我想，把鲍里斯·约翰逊比作詹姆斯二世，他做了所有那些事情，那位天主教君主，显然对盖伊·福克斯之夜不太高兴。所以鲍里斯是谁？我是说，鲍里斯看起来确实是一个相当17世纪的人物，不是吗？喧闹的，有点吵闹的，稍微不可靠的，确实非常不可靠，有些人可能会说。他是谁？查理二世？是的，我是说，当他在特蕾莎·梅之后上台时，特蕾莎·梅是一个著名的圆颅党式人物，清醒而务实，我想他的崇拜者们有一种感觉，他会成为一个快乐的君主。他会和卖橘子的女孩混在一起，剧院会开放，会有穿着褶边和丝绸的骑士，喧闹而狂欢。但当然，过去一年的经历，他基本上变成了奥利弗·克伦威尔。他只是到处禁止一切，拒绝一切。
I think, comparing Boris Johnson to James II, who did all those things, the Catholic monarch, who obviously was not very happy about Guy Fawkes' night. So who is Boris? I mean, Boris does seem quite a 17th century figure, doesn't he? Rumbustious, kind of boisterous, slightly unreliable, indeed very unreliable, some might say. Who is he? Charles II? Yes, I mean, when he came in after Theresa May, who was a kind of famously roundhead figure, sober and doer, I think there was a feeling on the part of his admirers that he was going to be a kind of merry monarch. And he'd be hanging out with orange sellers and the theatres would be open and there'd be cavaliers in ruffs and silks, roistering and doistering. But of course, the experience of the past year, he's basically turned into Oliver Cromwell. He's just rushed around banning everything and turning things down.
虽然必须说，当然，著名的是，人们认为克伦威尔禁止了圣诞节。所以禁止圣诞节很有趣，不是吗？所以他们确实禁止了圣诞节，因为他们认为清教徒——这是在1640年代和1650年代——因为他们认为圣诞节不应该全是欢乐、礼物和塞满巧克力。它实际上应该关于对神性的静默沉思
Although important to say, of course, famously, that people think Cromwell banned Christmas. So the banning Christmas is interesting, isn't it? So they kind of did ban Christmas because they didn't think the Puritans, this is, in the 1640s and 1650s, because they thought that Christmas shouldn't be all about jollity and presents and sort of stuffing yourself with chocolate. It should actually be about silent contemplation of the divinity of
基督或什么的。那是对的吗？他们不支持给予肉体和感官享受的自由。对。这当然基本上就是鲍里斯·约翰逊所代表的，也就是，好吧，他就是代表肉体享受，他代表肉体和感官享受，不是吗？我是说，我认为这非常符合他的风格，这就是为什么，顺便说一句，是的，他关闭商店，你知道，告诉人们他们不能聚集和玩乐，这确实是一个相当大的转变。但克伦威尔本人，有一件奇怪的事情，不是吗？人们认为克伦威尔非常严肃，克伦威尔是特蕾莎·梅，然而克伦威尔本人实际上是一个快乐得多的人物。我是说，有关于他在女儿婚礼上的故事，你知道，跳舞
Christ or whatever. Is that right? They were not in favour of giving liberty to carnal and sensual delights. Right. Which, of course course is pretty much what boris johnson is about which is well he is what he's about carnal delight he's about carnal and sensual delights isn't he i mean i think that's very much his kind of shtick um which is why by the way yes that he's kind of closing down shops and you know telling people that they can't gather and have fun is is kind of quite the transformation but cromwell himself there's this weird thing isn't it that people think cromwell was terribly door and that cromwell was theresa may and yet cromwell himself actually was a much more jolly figure i mean there's sort of stories about him at his daughter's wedding yeah you know dancing
玩得很开心。我一直认为克伦威尔是个很有趣的人。总之，他热爱音乐，他也热爱音乐，热爱音乐，是的。我们这里有另一个问题，休·伯恩说，关于取消圣诞节的主题，你能谈谈奥利弗·克伦威尔是英雄还是恶棍吗？我一直认为理查德·哈里斯让他演得很有感染力。你看过那部电影吗，汤姆？理查德·哈里斯饰演克伦威尔，是的，多年前。还有亚历克·吉尼斯。亚历克·吉尼斯是一位出色的查理一世，实际上。是的，我这一生中有两位伟大的查理一世，亚历克·吉尼斯和彼得·卡帕尔蒂在电视上扮演他。是的，他演得很好，不是吗？是的，他演得很好。
and having great a great i think of cromwell as a great laugh anyway well he loved his music he loved his music as well loved his music yeah we've got another question here Hugh Bourne says on the theme of cancelling Christmas can you talk about Oliver Cromwell hero or villain I always thought Richard Harris made him quite compelling you seen that film Tom Richard Harris playing Cromwell yes years ago and that's Alec Guinness Alec Guinness is uh Alec Guinness is a brilliant Charles the First actually yeah there have been two great Charles the First in my lifetime um Alec Guinness and Peter Capaldi played him on telly. Yes, he was very good, wasn't he? Yes, he was very good.
是的，他是，是的。他是最好的。那是一种煽动性的、左翼的东西。我记得全是关于约翰·利尔本和平等派的。彼得·卡帕尔蒂抢尽了风头，某种程度上模仿了亚历克·吉尼斯饰演的查理一世。好吧，谈到这个话题，当然，另一个有趣的相似之处是平等派，
Yes, he was, yes. He was the best. It was sort of agitprop, lefty kind of. It was all about John Lilburn, as I remember, and the Levellers. And Peter Capaldi stole the show, sort of channeling Alec Guinness playing Charles I. Well, on the topic of that, of course, that's another intriguing parallel, is the Levellers,
那些在当时非常激进的人，非常普遍的选举权，所有那些东西。所以他们是17世纪的科尔宾主义者。好吧，或者更具体地说是贝恩主义者，因为作为托尼·贝恩的忠实崇拜者，你会知道，托尼·贝恩带着巨大的兴奋发现了平等派，没人听说过他们，我想，他没有吗？他把奥利弗·克伦威尔比作哈罗德·威尔逊，这似乎……不，他，是的，他说，我是1970年代的平等派。
people who had very radical, for the time, very kind of universal suffrage, all that kind of stuff. So they're the sort of Corbynistas of the 17th century well well or more specifically the benites because you as a huge admirer of tony ben will know that that um that tony ben kind of discovered the levelers with a huge sense of excitement ever heard of them and i think tony ben's own mind no one had ever heard of them and i think didn't he he tony blen kind of um he compared Oliver Cromwell to Harold Wilson, which seems... No, he, yes, he said, he said, I'm the leveller of the 1970s.
你知道，我是那种为人民而战的英雄，是社会主义新黎明的先知。他说，那么谁是克伦威尔？好吧，要么是哈罗德·威尔逊，要么是丹尼斯·希利。我是说，显然是丹尼斯·希利。任何了解情况的人，我是说，这是一个完全不同的麻烦。任何了解1970年代的人都会知道，丹尼斯·希利会从使用军队镇压他的激进对手中获得巨大的快感。我是说，我认为这确实突出了另一种方式，
You know, I'm this sort of hero who fights for the people and is, you know, the prophet of the socialist new dawn. And he says, so who's the Cromwell? Well, it's either Harold Wilson or Dennis Healy. I mean, it's clearly Dennis Healy. Anyone who knows anything, I mean, it's a whole different can of worms. Anyone who knows anything about the 1970s will know Dennis Healy would have derived great pleasure from using the army to crush his radical opponents. I mean, I think that kind of does highlight another way
当我们把17世纪与今天进行比较时，这不仅仅是关于某种淡淡的倾向性相似之处。这也是关于一种血统感。这种血统感往往是虚假的，但人们会采纳并相信它。所以迈克尔·富特的父亲，艾萨克·富特，著名地说道，你知道，我想知道关于某人的事情是，他在马斯顿荒原战役中会站在哪一边？那是圆颅党和骑士党、议会和国王之间内战的决定性战役之一。
in which when we compare the 17th century to the present day, it's not just about kind of maybe faintly tendentious parallels. It's also about this kind of sense of a line of descent. And the line of descent is often quite a bogus one, but it gets picked up by people and believed in it. So Michael Foote's father, Isaac Foote, famously said that, you know, what I want to know about someone is which side would he have fought on at the Battle of Marston Moor, one of the decisive battles in the civil war between roundheads and cavaliers, between Parliament and King.
而迈克尔·富特，你知道，我是说，对这一切读得非常多，完全认同那种，你知道，伟大的事业，异议。我会站在哪一边？我是一个天生保守的人，总是转向胜利者。所以我猜我一开始会为国王而战，然后迅速转向为议会而战。这很有趣。我一直，我是说，我也是一个天生保守的人，
And Michael Foot, who was, you know, I mean, incredibly well read in all this, absolutely identified with that kind of, you know, the good old cause, the dissenting. Which side would I have fought on? I am a kind of naturally conservative person who always swings round to the victor. So I imagine I would have begun fighting for the king and then swung round very rapidly to fight for parliament. That's interesting. I've always been, I mean, I'm quite a naturally conservative person too,
但我一直认为我会成为一个圆颅党。我是说，我确实有一个非常圆的头。哦，确实有那个。是的。你不可能戴那种软塌塌的帽子，因为它根本戴不住。但我把自己看作是那种人，你知道，我会完全赞成后来对激进主义的镇压，
but I always thought I would be a roundhead. I mean, I genuinely have a very round head. Oh, there is that. Yes. You couldn't have worn one of those floppy hats because it just wouldn't have stayed on. But I sort of see myself as one of those people who, you know, I'd be all in favour of the later crackdown on radicalism
以及，你知道，使用少将，正如克伦威尔所做的那样，去镇压反对派，去夺走革命的所有乐趣和精神。这就是我所代表的。那会是你的风格。是的，绝对。绝对。我喜欢那种严肃。我真的很喜欢。我想成为一名骑士会更有趣。哦，会。当然会。
and on, you know, using the major generals, as Cromwell did, to kind of crush opposition and to sort of take all the fun and spirit out of the revolution. That's what I'm all about. That would have been your thing. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. The doerness I love. I really like that. I think it would have been more fun to be a cavalier. Oh, it would. Of course it would.
但显然不是在克伦威尔统治下，因为那样太冒险了。不。你想象自己戴着褶边。我可以成为一个布雷牧师式的人物，布雷牧师著名地随风倒。所以我认为这可能就是我会做的。我不认为我会对任何事业有足够的信念去采取强硬立场。所以你会是其中之一，我是说，我们谈到了这些家伙
But obviously not under Cromwell, because then it would be too risky. No. You see yourself wearing a ruff. I could be a kind of Vicar of Bray figure, who is the Vicar of Bray famously swinging with the wind. So I think that's probably what I would have done. I don't think I would have believed in either cause strongly enough to have taken a strong position on it. So you'd have been one of, I mean, we talked about these guys
在上一集里，俱乐部成员。是的，是的。我认为他们相当，他们看起来相当乡村。没关系。他们不在咖啡馆里读这些新奇的报纸，对吧？你知道，他们主要集中在威尔特郡，也就是我来自的地方，他们有点在树林里闲逛，我挺喜欢在树林里闲逛的，我不知道，是的，我们走着瞧。总之，但我同意你的观点，汤姆，关于
in the last episode, the club men. Yeah, yeah. I regard them as quite, they seem quite rustic. That's all right. They're not in they're not in coffee houses reading these newfangled newspapers are they you know they're centred very much in Wiltshire which is where I come from and they they kind of hang out in woods and I quite like hanging out in the wood I don't know yeah we'll see anyway um but I agree with you Tom on the
异议的严肃观点，顺便说一句，我认为追溯，你知道，保守主义和自由主义，后来的保守党和工党，甚至脱欧和留欧。它们可以，我是说，当然，这有点虚假，但你可以从17世纪的巨大激情中梳理出一条异议线。有一本精彩的书，你可能非常熟悉，罗伯特·图姆斯教授的《英国人与他们的历史》，他是一位脱欧派，也是剑桥教授。他基本上认为英国政治是一场关于17世纪意义的巨大争论。你知道，我们的辉格党和托利党，是在17世纪末出现的。
serious point about the dissent by the way I think trace, you know, conservatism and liberalism, later conservatives and Labour, even leave and remain. They can, I mean, of course, it is a bit spurious, but you can kind of tease out a line of dissent from the great passions of the 17th century. And there's a brilliant book, which you probably know very well, The English and Their History by Professor Robert Toombs, who's a Brexiteer and a Cambridge professor. And he basically argues that British politics is a huge argument about the meaning of the 17th century. You know, our Whigs and Tories, which kind of come about at the end of the 17th century.
以及这种，约翰牛式的托利党愿景与那种异议、高尚和清教主义精神之间的分歧。你可以追溯这些东西，不是吗？是的，我认为有趣的是在脱欧投票后进行的一些研究，
And this sort of, the division between, you know, the sort of Tory vision of the sort of John Bull and all of that kind of thing. And then the spirit of dissent and high-mindedness and Puritanism. You can trace those things back, can't you? Yeah, I think that what is interesting is a number of studies that were done in the wake of the Brexit vote,
这些研究绘制了在内战中支持国王和支持议会的地区，以及那些投票支持脱欧和投票支持留欧的地区。匹配度相当高。那是伦敦。那是那些从与欧洲大陆经济的密切联系中获利的地区，无论是在21世纪还是在17世纪。
which mapped areas that supported the king in the Civil War and supported Parliament onto areas that had voted for Brexit and those that had voted for Remain. And the match was pretty good. It was London. It was the kind of areas that have profited from close contacts with the European continental economy, both in the 21st century and in the 17th century.
而在17世纪，那是被遗忘的地区。而在17世纪，那是被遗忘的地区，支持了国王。所以国王就是脱欧。这就是你想说的。这就是Maddy的观点。但本质上，是的，本质上保皇党地区与支持脱欧的地区相吻合。是的，这很有趣，不是吗？
And it was kind of the left behind areas and in the 17th century. And it was kind of the left behind areas that in the 17th century had backed the king. So the king is Brexit. That's what you're saying. That's what Maddy's at. But essentially, yes, essentially the royalist areas map onto the Brexit supporting areas. Yeah, that's interesting, isn't it?
因为脱欧派，超级热情的脱欧派，像丹尼尔·汉南那样的疯子，那位托利党欧洲议会议员，他们认为自己是圆颅党的后裔。但这就是它的光荣之处，没有明确的血统线。这一切都令人难以置信地困惑和混乱。托利党和辉格党到底是谁，我是说，他们一直在转换阵营，在17世纪末到18世纪的过程中。所以那种血统感
Because Brexiteers, super keen Brexiteers, sort of loonies like Daniel Hannan, the Tory MEP, they see themselves as the descendants of the Roundheads. But that's what's so glorious about it, is that there is no clear line of descent. It's all incredibly confusing and muddling. And exactly who Tories and Whigs are, I mean, they're kind of constantly switching sides and over the course of the late 17th century into the 18th century. So that sense of a line of dissent
是有的，又好像没有。维多利亚时代也是如此，维多利亚时代政治分歧对立双方的人们将自己与保皇党，特别是与克伦威尔联系起来。我是说，克伦威尔作为自由主义之父的感觉，这解释了为什么那座雕像立在议会大厦外。这并不是真的关于克伦威尔本人。这是关于晚期维多利亚时代的自由主义者如何理解
is kind of there and kind of not. And the same in the Victorian period, the way in which people on opposite sides of the political divide in the Victorian period are identifying themselves with the Royalists, particularly with Cromwell. I mean, the sense of Cromwell as the father of liberalism, which is, you know, I mean, it explains why that statue is up outside the Houses of Parliament. It's not really about Cromwell himself. It's about how late Victorian liberals understand
他们自己。而且，你知道，这又是历史魅力的一部分，人们不断地使用它，并通过使用它来改变它的意义。而且我认为，实际上，你知道，在国家现在面临的另一个巨大的政治分歧上，我们再次看到了这一点，那就是英格兰和苏格兰之间的关系。是的，当然。因为，你知道，关于17世纪的事情是，它为我们提供了一个独立的苏格兰从英格兰和威尔士切断后，它可能看起来是什么样子的模型。
themselves. And, you know, that again is part of the fascination of the history, is that people are constantly using it, and by using it are kind of changing the sense of it. And I think that actually, you know, on another kind of huge political division that the country is facing now, again, we see that, which is the relationship between England and Scotland. Yeah, of course. Because, you know, the thing about the 17th century is that that provides us with a model of what an independent Scotland cut loose from England and Wales, what it might look like.
而且我认为这也许不是一个例子。我想它会以同样的方式开始，汤姆，一个女人向一个人的十字架扔凳子，关于新的祈祷书。这就是你看待尼古拉·斯特金的方式吗？好吧，我确实认为……所以导致震撼整个英国和爱尔兰的内战的事情之一，是查理一世试图强加……
And I think that it's perhaps not an example. I think it would start in the same way, Tom, with a woman throwing a stool at a person's cross about the new prayer book. Is that how you see Nicola Sturgeon? Well, I do think... So one of the things that ends up precipitating the civil wars that convulses the whole of Britain and Ireland is the attempt by Charles I to impose...
我认为这或许不是一个例子。汤姆，我认为它会以同样的方式开始，一位妇女因为新的祈祷书而向某人的十字架投掷凳子。你就是这样看待尼古拉·斯特金的吗？嗯，我确实认为……所以，最终导致震撼整个英国和爱尔兰的内战的导火索之一，是查理一世试图强加……
Your prayer book. Yeah, a particular model of religion and what is seen in Scotland as an English model of religion on Scotland. You look at it and you can see that this religious stuff matters profoundly. It's capable of shaking entire nations. It completely affects how people see and understand the world. And the print of that endures even after Christian faith perhaps evaporates. And I think that the line of descent of modern Scottish nationalism from a kind of biblically infused sense of the Scots as being an elect is absolutely a part of contemporary politics. As listeners will know, it takes very little effort to get Tom to opine for hours on end
你的祈祷书。是的，这是一种特定的宗教模式，在苏格兰被视为一种英国式的宗教模式。你审视它，就能看出这些宗教事物有着深远的影响。它有能力撼动整个国家。它彻底影响了人们看待和理解世界的方式。即使基督教信仰可能已经消散，这种影响的印记依然存在。我认为现代苏格兰民族主义从一种带有圣经色彩的“苏格兰人是上帝选民”的意识中衍生出来的脉络，绝对是当代政治的一部分。正如听众们所知，要让汤姆滔滔不绝地发表几个小时的见解，几乎不需要费什么力气。
about his thoughts on A, Christianity, and B, Scottish nationalism. But we're running out of time. Just one last thought. Witches. This is the great age of witch hunting and witch burning. And I can't help thinking of somebody else with Scottish, or certainly Scottish associations, J.K. Rowling, and the online attacks on her and all that. Is there any parallel there with witch hunts of the 17th century?
关于他对以下两点的看法：A，基督教；B，苏格兰民族主义。但我们的时间快到了。最后一个想法。女巫。这是猎巫和焚烧女巫的伟大时代。我不禁想到了另一个人，她与苏格兰有着某种联系，或者至少是苏格兰关联，那就是J.K.罗琳，以及网络上对她的攻击等等。这与17世纪的猎巫运动有什么相似之处吗？
I think that J.K. Rowling is more significant as a kind, I mean, she's the equivalent of a religious leader, because witches were, by and large, they were kind of uneducated people who could be punished precisely because they were so marginal, precisely because they didn't have a loud voice. J.K. Rowling has an incredible voice, and that's what's made her a lightning rod, both the people who support her position and those who don't. So I think that J.K. Rowling is kind of someone who's very active in the equivalent of what would have been in the 17th century pamphlet wars. But that impetus to find scapegoats, to name and shame people who have fallen from the true faith, to attribute the ills of society to the moral failings of particular individuals, particularly people who you can pick on and you can kind of bully.
我认为J.K.罗琳的意义更重大，我的意思是，她相当于一位宗教领袖，因为女巫在很大程度上是那种未受教育的人，她们之所以受到惩罚，恰恰是因为她们处于边缘地位，恰恰是因为她们没有话语权。J.K.罗琳拥有令人难以置信的影响力，这使她成为了众矢之的，无论是支持她立场的人还是反对她的人。所以我认为J.K.罗琳在某种程度上非常活跃，相当于17世纪的小册子战争。但那种寻找替罪羊、点名羞辱那些背离真理信仰的人、将社会弊病归咎于特定个人的道德缺陷的冲动，特别是针对那些你可以欺负和霸凌的人。
I mean, that feels very, you know, like 17th century witch hunting, doesn't it? Yes, and I think what's interesting, I mean, pulling out from just Britain and looking at the whole of Europe, one of the incredibly depressing things about the witch craze is that it's pretty much the only ecumenical thing that happens it's the only thing that catholics and protestants completely share in is a desire to persecute witches and again maybe that's something that we see in the present that the um actually there's perhaps more that joins extremes of left and right yeah then so much divides us but we can all unite around turning on on women who speak out of place yeah oh god um let us move on to a very different subject very quickly right at the end a quick note from the fabulously named cfjc75 so presumably a cousin
我的意思是，这感觉非常像17世纪的猎巫运动，不是吗？是的，我认为有趣的是，如果跳出英国，审视整个欧洲，猎巫狂热中最令人沮丧的事情之一就是，它是几乎唯一一件具有普世性的事情，这是天主教徒和新教徒完全共同参与的唯一一件事，那就是迫害女巫的欲望。也许我们在当下也能看到这一点，实际上，左右两派极端之间可能比我们想象的更有共同点，尽管我们之间存在分歧，但我们都能团结起来攻击那些言论不当的女性。噢天哪，让我们快速转向一个完全不同的话题。在最后，来自名字非常棒的cfjc75的一条简短留言，大概是C3PO的表亲。
of c3po uh gentleman he says he's a fine judge, or she's a very fine judge. Gentleman, just enjoyed your first two podcasts while walking around Greenwich Park. It would be great if you did a podcast on history book recommendations from each century and each decade of the 20th century. Well, that is a good idea. I think we should just do a quick recommendation about the 17th century. Tom, give us a couple of 17th century books that you think listeners might enjoy. Well, I mentioned one already, which is Geoffrey Parker's Global Crisis. Not just about Britain, about the whole sweep of the world. Really stupefying book and interesting in almost every way it's possible to be interesting. I'd also recommend a book that came out earlier this
的一位绅士，他说他是一位很好的法官，或者她是一位非常好的法官。先生们，刚刚在格林威治公园散步时听了你们的前两期播客。如果你们能做一期关于20世纪每个世纪和每个年代的历史书籍推荐的播客，那就太棒了。嗯，这真是个好主意。我想我们应该快速推荐一下关于17世纪的书籍。汤姆，给我们推荐几本你认为听众可能会喜欢的17世纪书籍吧。嗯，我已经提到过一本了，就是杰弗里·帕克的《全球危机》。不仅仅是关于英国，而是关于整个世界。真是一本令人震惊的书，在任何可能的方面都非常有趣。我还想推荐一本今年早些时候出版的书，
year. Paul Lay's fantastic book uh the protectorate cromwell's period in power um called providence lost so play there on paradise lost um incredibly readable incredibly gripping um completely fascinating and i'll give a couple of uh my own a couple of older books uh there's a book on crromwell called God's Englishman by Christopher Hill, which is short. A lot of 17th century books are very long, so it's a short book, and it really gets under Cromwell's skin and is a great introduction to the period, actually. And the other book is one of my favourite books of all time, which I think absolutely everybody should read, even if they have no interest in history of the 17th century at all, which is
保罗·莱那本精彩的书，关于克伦威尔掌权时期的护国公政体，书名叫《失去的普罗维登斯》，这是对《失乐园》的戏仿，非常易读，引人入胜，完全令人着迷。我还要推荐几本我自己的旧书，有一本关于克伦威尔的书叫克里斯托弗·希尔写的《上帝的英国人》，篇幅很短。很多17世纪的书都很长，所以这是一本短书，它真正深入了解了克伦威尔的内心，实际上是了解那个时期的绝佳入门书。另一本书是我有史以来最喜欢的书之一，我认为绝对每个人都应该读，即使他们对17世纪的历史完全不感兴趣，那就是
The Diary of Samuel Pepys. Now, it's very long, but you can read short versions. And I can't think of many other books that get you into the mind of somebody living in an entirely different era. I mean, you know, Samuel Pepys, by the time you finish that book, as well as you know yourself or your husband or your wife or your closest friends, and you kind of, you know, you're living in his head. It's a fantastic book, a fantastic guide to what life was actually like sort of on the ground in the 17th century. And Dominic, just before we end, one novel which I think is possibly absolutely top of my list of historical novels, it's called Instance of the Fingerpost by Ian Pears
《塞缪尔·佩皮斯日记》。这本书很长，但你可以读简写本。我想不出还有什么书能让你进入一个完全不同时代的人的内心世界。我的意思是，当你读完那本书时，你对塞缪尔·佩皮斯的了解程度，就像了解你自己、你的丈夫、你的妻子或你最亲密的朋友一样，你就像是活在他的脑海里。这是一本精彩的书，是了解17世纪现实生活的一本绝佳指南。多米尼克，在结束之前，还有一本小说，我认为可能绝对是我历史小说清单上的首选，书名叫伊恩·皮尔斯的《指点迷津》
and it's set against the backdrop of the end of the protectorate, the restoration of Charles II. It's a kind of a mystery. You have four different perspectives. The denouement is out of this world. Do read it. It's brilliant.
它的背景设定在护国公政体结束、查理二世复辟时期。这是一个悬疑故事。你有四个不同的视角。结局简直太棒了。一定要读读看。它非常精彩。
I could not agree with you more, Tom. That is an absolutely brilliant book. I remember I stayed up all night reading that book. It's so rifting. It's right up there with The Secret History or The Name of the Rose or any of these kind of great books. It's one of the great, great historical novels. It is indeed.
汤姆，我完全同意你的看法。那真是一本绝对精彩的书。我记得我通宵达旦地读那本书。它太吸引人了。它和《秘史》或《玫瑰的名字》或任何这类伟大的书一样出色。它是最伟大的历史小说之一。确实如此。
Well, anyway, I kind of feel we've only scratched the surface and there is so much more to say, but we've had fun and I hope you have too. So that's it for this week. Thank you for listening. We're going to be here every Monday to start your week with a historical bang. Historical bang, who knows what that could be. So do please subscribe. Do please rate us on Apple Podcasts
好吧，无论如何，我觉得我们只是触及了皮毛，还有很多话要说，但我们玩得很开心，希望你们也一样。这就是本周的全部内容。感谢收听。我们每周一都会在这里，以历史的震撼开启你的一周。历史的震撼，谁知道那会是什么呢。所以请务必订阅。请务必在Apple Podcasts上给我们评分
and thank you for listening. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。再见。感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需获取额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。网址是restishistorypod.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。